a thirst to study amidst the lockdown
and under the shadow of the coronavirus
these children from the poorest of the
poor gather every day
as if it was regular classes
a makeshift school run by satinderpal
shakya
a university student himself has come
most
handy during the pandemic sitting on
rugs these children are unperturbed by
the banging of heavy equipment
around them the under construction
flyover also protects them from the
elements
schools have been shut since march and
all learning is to be done by online
classes
but for the millions of poor children
it's a privilege
they cannot afford
[Music]
[Music]
the digital divide is stark even in the
nation's capital
most of india lives in its villages
with such facilities are scarce and
lacking
a fear that many may be left out of
education
14 year old rahul is in grade 10 a
crucial year
he's seen his grades in maths and
sciences improve
by these offline classes
so
the only covered classroom is full
some semblance of school the months of
lockdown of educational institutions and
schools
across this country has come out with
its own complexities
a digital divide where millions of
children
of marginalized communities have borne
the brunt on their education
after class rahul is back home to help
his father in the fields
a sheikh cropper dayaram just about
manages to eke out a living
from his patch the contagion has drained
him of all his savings
unable to provide for his children's
digital classes
for the moment the free school is the
only saving grace
neville lazarus sky news delhi